hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to spewer now this is one of
my favourite games to ever come out of
new grounds now new grounds it is a
place if you've never been to it before
it's a website that featured a lot of
great animators and game creators of the
past who have since moved on to
different things and it's kind of sad
because Newgrounds isn't as big as it
used to be but it's still hosted some of
the most influential games that I've
played in the past and this is easily
one of my favorites I was talking with
Aaron and Ross egoraptor and Robert
ninja who started on Newgrounds just
like a lot of people did a home moved on
to different avenues but this game is
fantastic like if you've never played it
before and I highly recommend that you
do and I won't be able to get through
the whole game in this video alone but I
highly recommend that you play it for
yourself it's addicting it's fantastic
it's cute it's adorable
and it is involved look at how many
levels are involved with just the main
game and also you spew you literally use
your puke as a method of movement in
this game now I didn't necessarily need
to do that if this is a tutorial stages
and it'll teach you exactly how you're
gonna be able to get through stuff and
you can swim through your own puke and
vile and goop and it's going to be
phenomenal and adorable and kind of
disgusting but that's kind of the charm
of it but maybe you don't like that but
either way it's a great game and I'm
gonna play through it as best I can
oh and by the way you can eat up your
puke again if you feel so inclined with
the space bar so anyway you jump you
puke you jump in puke you avoid the
death you got a scientist looking over
your shoulder the whole time and that's
pretty much the most of the game the
puzzles get more and more complex as you
go along and I know this seems a lot
like a game review and not so much as
you know just me herb interpreter but
this is like oops
I pressed R which I accidentally reset
the game but I mean this is one of the
games that I am really nostalgic about
and one of the cool things about being
around Aran and Ross of the game grumps
and all the other game grumps is that I
get to talk about these old passions of
mine that I really it's weird because I
wasn't a creator at that point I didn't
make my own stuff and in a lot of ways I
wish I did I was so focused on like
school
and whatnot now I'm not saying that you
guys should quit school at any time but
I mean if you got a passion for creating
like this is a great example of what
comes out of a community that while at
the same time heavily critiques creation
but also you know it allows for these
incredible things to come out of it that
never really would have come out before
because now you know indie game
development has reached two different
branches there's the indie game
development that still makes for the
sake of creating and then there's the
indie game development that makes for
the sake of you know app development and
making games on mobile and trying to
make a lot of money which admittedly
they should because when game makers
made games on Newgrounds they didn't
make any money out of it it was very
hard to monetize it especially since it
was a community that emphasized free
games and this game is free it's huge
it's extensive it was made just for the
respect of the peers and the enjoyment
of the players and possibly making some
money out of it like Super Meat Boy went
on to becoming a full-fledged game
released on Steam I believe which is
fine totally fine and I've got nothing
wrong with people making money from
their creations but back then most
people didn't like most people did not
make money out of their games and even
though this one is adorable
fantastically made physically based and
is probably more advanced and more well
put together than a lot of games that
you'll see today it still didn't make a
lot of money or at least I don't think
it did so anyway back to the game of
hand I'm right now trying to push
buttons and try to get through the game
I actually know this game very well even
though I died right then in there and
you might recognize the blood explosion
from Super Meat Boy because yes I
believe that's what it was from but at
the same time it's just like I got so
many thoughts when I think about this
like the game is important because you
need to recycle your puke whenever you
can so that you don't run out at the
wrong time and this game actually has a
pretty interesting story like you might
see some things in the background there
where this scientist is running
experiments on me the little spewer
that I am but god I might my train of
thought is going in so many different
directions that I keep forgetting
exactly where I'm trying to be at the
moment like points like this chapter one
completed actually shows some things in
the background and this scientists who
have
weird devil horns for hairs you can
actually read in the back down now I
didn't actually read in the background
before because I was just playing the
game let's see it says like ESC V to
treatment on mini inconclusive funding
needed for ESC v3 $4,000
hey rant so this guy's hurting for money
and he's trying to treat Mindy for
something or other you guys will find
out more about that later you can eat
things other than your own vomit pills
will make you throw up in new impossibly
exciting ways fruit fills you up and
tastes great but that's fantastic so now
I get a new spewing power which is
actually like clouds it is so cool like
everything about this game was like
awesome it was just fantastic that the
ideas and the possibilities behind some
of the cool games that came out on
Newgrounds were enormous ly phenomenal
like I can't even imagine I'm having a
nostalgia gasm just it from what has
happened in the past in the games that
I've I've had the privilege of being
able to play now now I can't say that
all of them were great there was some
pretty pretty terrible games sometimes
but other than like besides that there
were actually some some of my favorite
games of all time came out of the
Newgrounds era I cannot speak highly
enough about these games and even though
I I would I would be sad to hear if some
of them look down upon like triple games
because some people's careers have been
triple-a and Frick I need to put some
there and I had some left I don't know
why I didn't spew enough but I would be
sad if they look down on triple-a or
kind of shied away from that and I've
said some bad things about Triple A
games just because I feel like it's not
creative but that doesn't mean that the
people making them aren't also creative
because some of them like they came out
of this and Newgrounds who started by
kids who just wanted to make cool things
like Erin and Ross they tell me cuz
they're my aides they're my age and and
they started making when I was just
goddamnit I I remember this one was
particularly hard because it introduced
a new concept and it was rather
unforgiving right off the bat so I need
to be able to do this hang on let me let
me actually focus on beating this
instead of talking about my past
which I guess is fine I can talk about
my past
if I want to it's my pass no god damn it
ah god this is not going well I can do
this though I think I need to eat less
of what's here and I think actually that
was my mistake when I first did this I
can actually just kind of go maybe hit
my yeah yeah okay yeah that was it I was
an idiot I kept trying to eat things and
recycle it forward and move it along I
wasn't supposed to do that at all
fruit oh goody goody gumdrops fruit lets
you puke puke lets you move where you
need to go it just wanted I wish that
someone would remix this game so that
there's actually like a Oh God like if
Aaron actually put his voice into the
screaming it acted be really funny but
maybe not might remove some of the
cuteness from it anyway
wolves have scenes pulling before I'm
sorry that my vocal mining my thoughts
are so scrabbled because like there's so
much that I want to say there's so much
to be said about like these types of
games and what could be brought about
from and how it reflects on how indie
games are made today because there's a
new game developers coming out all the
time but when people started here this
is what I was i'ma is they were kids
like people who started out on
Newgrounds were legitimately just
children III don't mean that in an
insulting way they were kids they were
young they were young but they weren't
on they were uninhibited by anything
else and they were influenced by the
other creators on the site which allowed
some of the coolest creations to come
out of it and some of the coolest
creations to ever come out of gaming to
be explored in this space like just be
you know it was like an adventure of
what could be done in gaming and and
also animation as well like Newgrounds
was also a big animation thing and I'm
not saying it was perfect I don't mean
to like some people are gonna take this
the wrong way and think that I I think
that this was better than any other
moment in the history of gaming but no
that that's not true but not to be
misconstrued it's half true it's half
true and half not true some of my
personal favorite games came out of new
ground I am rambling completely and I'm
probably not making any sense at all but
this is cool here because this is
actually where things start to get
interesting because it always
it always introduced new concepts new
concepts that weren't a part of many
other games but were easy to understand
like this is where it introduces the
concept of acid being bad but also that
your puke can interact and mix with it
in different ways and it can show that
that's something in this game and
something that's a basic function of
this game now it's like it's very
elegant in what it is and it's very cool
in the game design that it has and it
shows that there like the basic
principles of game designs were relevant
even in an atmosphere where gaming was
still kind of exploring new ground in
mainstream like Nintendo and Microsoft
and whatever have you game developers
making triple-a titles that explored new
ventures in what could be done in terms
of processing power but gameplay itself
was also this new and not quite
perfected area where like concept like
this were explored in adventures and ha
he died goddamnit
I need to pay attention to actually what
I'm doing but like just this concepts
could be explored in new ways like who
would have thought that someone could
make a game where you're you're a little
you're a little ball and you're trying
to puke like that's literally all I'm
trying to do here that's all I'm ever
going to be doing in this game and it's
awesome because it can be explored in
many different ways and I'm saying the
same things over and over again I get
very worried when I play something that
I I thoroughly enjoy and I think is like
important and not to say that other
games that I played haven't been
important there they each have their
purpose and they each have things that
are good for them and great to do but
this game in particular is just is still
evil to me God that cannot get up there
am i I forget if I'm supposed to swim
through here nope can't go through there
so that's not it
I forget exactly what I'm supposed to do
I know I'm supposed to spew this over
here so that I can get to it up there
I'm pretty sure I was supposed to be
able to puke my way up there but I'm not
100% on that one maybe I just need some
more here in the base so that I could I
can have something to jump out of pick
up damn it
and I can get this I can get this or I
can this will be the end of my let's
play because I can't get any further
help oh come on right there god damn it
I can do this
I can do it it's Kimmy give me some time
give me some time eat here but also push
over here weep yes there we go okay
that's what I'm supposed to do gimme
gimme gimme get in my mouth get in my
mouth please thank you okay I'm gonna
stop nostalgia Gaza Ming and I'm
actually gonna focus on the game here
because I like as much as I would love
to talk for hours and hours and hours
about my favorite Newgrounds games of
the past and how gaming has developed
over time I need to focus on the task at
hand here oh crap I forget what am I
supposed to do here I think I'm supposed
to just jump over these things no okay
so there was a there's also like oh god
what the hell happened there physics got
a little wonky
remember this was all still made in
flash so I mean technically there still
are things that are a little wonky in
terms of physics but the fact that this
could be done period is still amazing no
oh no no there we go thank you okay okay
it's still he's such a happy little face
it's so cute and adorable and I don't
want to say anything bad about it
because it's really nothing bad to be
said and I'm not gonna play the whole
way through this game it's a very long
game or it's not a very long game but
it's longer than I'm gonna be playing on
this episode here I'm gonna get fairly
far but what I what I really want is for
you guys to go out and play yourself
like this is a game that should be
experienced like if there was ever a
game that I recommended that you play
and you actually come from that
drop-down on me what a piece of poop
this came scrapped don't blame now if it
was ever a game that I actually
recommended to you and I actually played
it would be this one because it's just
pure and simple delightful and this
piece of acid over here for some damn
reason ah oh I thought it was dead yeah
they liked to twitch and jiggle and move
around a little bit and I don't much
care for it but I'm still making my way
through like when I first played this
game it blew
my mind just like a lot of games from
new grounds at the time it just it's
just oh I can't I'll be the first to
admit that I'm totally biased I am
completely and utterly biased about
these games and I have a bias because
it's my scene nostalgia talking most of
the time and it's like part of my
history even though this one only came
out no 9 and admittedly that was still
six years ago today but still it's just
I wish nothing but success on the
creators of these cool games I just I
just count about it so much and I'm
sorry if I do but I love it I love it so
much
and like I bet Ross's in the other room
and hearing me right now it easily with
more going on about over there what's he
screaming about but this is so cool so
cool to see I was actually hunting down
games like this and I came across the
fewer and I just I remembered like I I
just remembered everything that came out
of it so spill goddamnit I keep clicking
outside of the box and I don't mean to
hang on actually kind of finicky this
game actually does get exceptionally god
damn it just do it right you dingus damn
it yeah you're making me look bad in
front of whole Internet
I kept talking about how great this game
was now let's talk about how great I am
at it yep there we go there we go there
we go okay thank you
gimme gimme gimme I don't know if I got
enough oh no I don't know if I got
enough please tell me that's enough it's
enough right oh yeah there we go okay so
is at the end of chapter 2 no I got one
more thing here alright sub-12 Oh for
brain damage caused by p13 revisions
needed many shows minimal response to
subbed one - oh three one two oh five
showing signs of retardation call Jeff
for funding retardation not in the term
of like mental retardation retardation
by definition means to be held back
anyway that's a whole nother story but
either way that's where I'm gonna leave
this because I want you guys to
experience this game for yourself if you
have not played it or if you have plated
for tell other people in the description
how fun this game is this is a
delightful game this is a fantastic game
you should play it's phenomenal
links in the description below and if
you're an old-new grass
yourself let me know I would love to
hear from you I would love to hear your
favorite games from this era and I know
that Newgrounds it's not as popular as
it used to be but it's still a hub for
creators to at least see the creations
of the past it's a great website and it
had a great purpose back in the day like
I loved everything that came out like
bitey of Bracken Wood is one of my
favorite animations Gemma is how I first
heard about egoraptor and it's why I'm
able to fangirl
at him and Ross as well and it's where
I'm able to like meet and know these
cool creators because III might be in
the same YouTube spaces emmm now but
like the only reason that we're we're
friends now is because I'm able to say
oh my god I love your animations you're
a huge inspiration to me and they are so
I just want to say thank you guys for
giving me this opportunity to meet these
cool people check out this game and
check out other great games that people
recommend in the description below or in
the comments below rather and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
oh no don't push him this way Oh God oh
this bad is bad oh no no oh I got a suit
of armor looks extra shiny it easy
enough to glowing duck for the
[Music]